if I had to write the story of my life today
it would be a very simple story
centred around a main character
who has to clean all of the things
over and over
every day
until the end of time
and today's narrative would be written
much like the rest of them if I'm honest
except plot twist
there's a shining new love interest in the form
of Ecostore’s Refill Concentrates
and the new protagonists are benevolent
and extremely easy to use
just pop them in a clean sprayer bottle
add 450ml of water and you're away
doesn't even need to be an Ecostore bottle
if you don't have one
side note and totally unrelated
but is it obvious
I've been disassociating a little bit much
on cleantok & booktok lately?
anyway I've just got the kids out of my hair
I mean off to school
and every weekday morning around here looks much the same
I like to try and take a quick 30 first thing
to reset the house
no matter how busy the day ahead is looking
it sets me up for a productive day
and I get a few blissful hours where I'm not surrounded by total chaos
which really helps with the old headspace
I've hit the kitchen with the Ecostore multi-purpose cleaner
which smells really good and is antibacterial
I dressed the table
which deludes me into believing that I've
actually got my life together
before tackling the console
which is collecting dust as if it's going out of fashion
then I swapped to a clean microfiber cause that one was toast
and also so I could tackle the mirrors with the
Ecostore glass cleaner for a streak free finish
I did the mirror in the dining room and the bathroom
before switching to the antibacterial bathroom cleaner
for the rest of the surfaces
okay so I've been using this range for my entire adult life
which feels like a really long time actually
but they do make really effective
environmentally conscious products
and they're also constantly innovating
these concentrates are just as good as a full size bottle
but they reduce plastic waste by 90%
and they're cheaper
find them at your local supermarket
and let me know what you think!